Well, our next guest doesn't have his finger
on the sound effects button for his show,
Mad Money. He has his finger on the pulse of
the world economy. Please welcome Jim
Cramer. Cram.
Thank you for having me.
How are you doing Jim. Man man I'm doing
well. Thank you. How about
you. Oh we can't complain I mean if we could
ain't nobody gonna listen.
You heard. You know what that is.
You know it is. It's called being black
walking down the street. Me being black.
You wake up in the morning and then you'd be
like, who's. Who's looking at me?
Ooh! Huh?
Understand? All right. Jim. It ain't about
us. It's about you, baby. Ah!
Who am I to contradict you?
That's right.
Hey, Jim, let's get to the hard stuff.
Is AI good for America, or should it scare
the sh*t out of us or both?
Well, look, I think that I have a partner in
the morning show, David Faber from squawk on
the Street. He's absolutely convinced that
it's going to crush us all.
You know, like Skynet.
You know, Terminator. I actually think it's
going to make us all smarter, and it's going
to help us to be more productive.
But from what I've seen so far, people are
their ingenuity is benefiting.
So if you have an idea, it could be like
times two with AI.
So I'm pro.
Will Twitter ever be worth what Elon Musk
paid for it?
Absolutely not. I mean, no way.
I mean, it's just like a just a real bad.
It's not even an investment.
It was a it was a gamble with some rip up,
you know, I mean it was like he took the
under and the score was 100.
I mean, he's that kind of thing. Wow.
Let me ask you, do you ever wear the jacket
on the show or is that just for.
Yes. Evening show. Absolutely not.
I mean, this is kind of what you see is what
you get right down sleeves, you know?
Eagles. Uh, there you go.
There you go. Philly guy.
Yeah. Oh, man. Is he a Philly guy.
And by the way, wearing no jacket and
rolling up your shirt. You know what that
means. It means he don't take no sh*t.
So when I'm giving you words, it's coming
straight from the no sh*t.
I don't take sh*t like Jim.
That's a Philadelphia attitude.
Right, Jim? Yeah.
No, I, I share that attitude.
I just don't really have the physique
anymore to really take them on like I used
to, but it's okay.
Well, our Eagles win the Super Bowl this
year.
Uh, yes.
What the. What the f*** was that?
Jim, what took you so long?
Yeah, honestly, I'm from Philadelphia.
I was debating whether I was going to jinx
it. You know what it's like? Yeah, right.
You want to jinx.
Me.
Right? Okay, so tell us, why is the NFL such
a good business? Is it the game?
Is it the gambling or is it fantasy?
What do you think it is?
I think I think fantasy made it so.
The fourth quarter is worth watching.
Fourth quarter is where all the action is
because of fantasy. 55 million people play
fantasy. A lot of people do daily fantasy
and they do it through, uh, DraftKings,
which is a real good stock.
And I recommend it.
Yeah, DraftKings is strong.
I think a lot of that has to do with the
personnel. When you just talk about the rise
and a brand or a company.
Yeah. So a lot of that and I'm not sure, you
know. Do you work for DraftKings?
Well, I'm not here to say what I do or don't
do, but I am a significant face attached to
the brand, so. Oh to his.
Yeah. To something big.
That up, something up. Yeah.
Shout out to Caesars. Yeah.
Huh? Wait, um. Wait a minute.
You said the track. That's not the same
thing. No, I got a good question for you,
Jim. Uh, Taylor Swift just became a
billionaire. Should she bought a team in the
NFL.
Okay, so once you're billionaire, you only
need to get rich once. She should just go
buy municipal bonds.
Okay?
You don't want to buy an NFL team because
that's just, uh, that's just vanity.
Break
down a municipal bond for the layman.
If you- Hold on, Jim, hold on.
You don't know what a municipal bond is.
I'm sorry, Kevin, you got to be sh*tting me.
Kenan. Come on, man, you do this.
I feel like you don't know either.
Oh, I don't know. Yeah, okay.
Do you let me ask you a question.
If you get a ticket at the zoo, can you see
the animals? I believe you, I believe you
can. All right, all right.
That means come on, come on, man, just a
couple of words of a municipal and the the
advantages of that.
When when a government wants to do, uh, raise
some money to be able to do something, uh,
they can go and use the bond market and they
can you can buy the bonds, and then you
don't have to pay any taxes on them, which
is what, you know, the New Jersey turnpikes.
Yeah.
Jim.
You're blowing his mind right now because
that's exactly what he was going to say.
No, I'm just saying, like, it's- so this is
. Dude, this is finance 101 financial 101 for
dummies. Let me ask you a question. You go
to a sneaker store, okay? You buy a pair of
sneakers. Yeah, right.
Are you gonna put them on?
Uh, not right away.
At some point, yes, eventually.
All right then.